this week Republicans move towards
finalizing their platform for next
week's Republican National Convention I
expected some craziness but it is way
more insane and outrageous than I even
imagined it would be especially
considering that on some issues there
presumptive nominee Donald Trump is
actually more moderate but maybe that is
why the Republicans have gone hard
Looney crazy right with their platform
here some of the big points from this
proposed Republican convention platform
to start with they want to ban women
from military combat okay we've already
talked about that if you have certain
requirements that need to be met to
participate in combat then it shouldn't
really matter which genitals you have
it's more a matter of are you equipped
to do the job Republicans apparently
don't want that women out of combat okay
uh the Republican platform that they are
putting forth the convention describes
coal as a clean energy source hard to
imagine a dirtier energy source than
call completely anti science completely
uh just absolutely nonsensical
retrograde idea the UH issue of
pornography has been declared a public
health crisis by the 2016 Republican
convention platform what planet are they
living on where you you say we are
laying out our broad political strategy
for the future of our country and we're
gonna focus on porn as a public health
crisis they've also rejected efforts
during these meetings around the
platform by moderates to add some
non-discrimination language for LGBT
individuals I mean this is just like
such a minor basic thing and they
couldn't even agree to do that that's
been rejected and this is where it
really goes cuckoo for cocoa puffs the
Republican platform is demanding that
lawmakers use religion as a guide when
legislating and that quote that man-made
law must be consistent with god-given
natural rights how man uh depressing
teachers are encouraged to use the Bible
in public school for teaching some
saying as a historical document okay I
mean it's not you can make a case that
there are certainly historical realities
that can be illustrated through the eggs
distance of the Bible but teaching the
content of the Bible itself as a
historical document is bonkers calls for
overturning that Supreme Court gay
marriage decision of course I mean that
is clearly a done deal they're still
talking about that they also want to
appoint Supreme Court justices that
respect traditional family values
traditional of course meaning uh
religiously oriented and hugely anti-gay
and lastly the Republican convention
platform for 2016 wants to promote state
laws to limit which restrooms
transgender people could use can you
think of a bigger waste of time for a
natural national political platform and
lastly the 2016 Republican convention
platform wants to make it very clear
Louis that parents should be free to
send their LGBT kids to gay conversion
therapy which fortunately has been
banned by California at least forget
about Trump Louis this is about a party
that has gone insane these are
anti-scientific provisions these are
provisions that violate the spirit of
the Constitution in terms of breaking
down separation of church and state this
is the equivalent of an ostrich with its
head in the sand yeah we've discussed
for years that they need to move more to
the center if they want a chance at
keeping at keeping people in office in
the future the Republican Party I'm
talking about of course and they seem to
be getting more extreme I mean it it
seems that every year their pandering to
two fewer and fewer people and what is
the point I mean it what needs to happen
for them to add I believe me I love this
I love this their platform I love that
they are not changing at all it's great
for Democrats the problem I see is that
this as Louis points out panders to the
more extreme elements of the Republican
Party who are often big donors but a lot
of the sort of all right Trump
supporters are just going to ignore this
because they'll say yeah you know what I
don't agree with a lot of that stuff but
I'm not voting for Hillary I'm voting
for Trump Trump wants to build the wall
he wants to ban Muslims although does he
really at this point we don't really
know and they will just say I can I can
swallow this stuff right I can deal with
this stuff
although I don't like it because big
picture Trump Trump Trump and that's the
danger that in a way this is indicative
of the fact that the problems with
elected Trump are way bigger than
elected trumpets also this ludicrous
platform that they put together yeah but
many of the all right trumpeters
trumpets whatever you want to call them
I just will ignore it and they'll say
hey you know I can compartmentalize that
stuff doesn't resonate with me but who
cares i'm still vote Trump no doubt and
I'm not as concerned with uh with Trump
when I look at this list I know that
this is not Trump's platform right uh he
is not concerned with most of the things
on this list and as president I don't
really know what he'll do uh with regard
to it but uh the nuts that might get
elected in yet that you at the state
level and and uh Congress it's that is a
bit more disturbing you have to assume
though that uh that as time goes on
they're just gonna start disappearing
well that's the scary thing because on
the one hand much of this much of these
convention platform bullet points number
one aren't even things the country by
and large agrees with at this point the
country has moved to the left on a lot
of these issues so that's a complete and
total disconnect the other disconnect is
that a lot of these things don't
coincide with Trump's platform and many
of the things that are in Trump's
platform will never happen right the
Muslim ban will never happen building
the wall will never happen changing
libel laws to sue journalists will never
happen so it's a complete guessing game
as to what would a trump republican
administration do because most of the
stuff the Republicans have put together
aren't even things that are are even
feasible or popular with much of their
base yeah and many of the things Trumper
suggesting or just total laughable
non-starters I have no clue what they'll
do maybe nothing yeah I mean would trump
veto some crazy transgender bill that
appears on his desk right now what what
would he veto that would come from these
nuts and it could get pretty crazy send
your thoughts on this i'm on twitter
addy pakman lewis is on twitter at louis
MO tommy i've talked about how people of
all ages but particularly millennials
are owning cars less and participating
more in the sharing economy and one of
the more popular options is zip car
which gets you a car when you want it
when you
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zipcar
dot-com / David